Hace unas semanas os hablábamos de esa relación
tan especial entre Estados Unidos y Arabia
Saudita, que ni siquiera el propio Donand
Trump se atreve a romper.
Sin embargo, hay algo que nos dejamos en el
tintero ¿Por qué Estados Unidos importa
petróleo de Arabia Saudí?
Recordad que, si sumamos los yacimientos que
hay en Texas y California más los recientemente
descubiertos en otros estados como Dakota
del Norte, el país Norteamericano es el tercer
productor de crudo del planeta.
Y aún así, necesita importar aún más petróleo
de otros países.
Y para más INRI, su principal suministrador
es la mayor teocracia islámica del planeta.
Para que os hagáis una idea, Arabia Saudí
es algo así como el Hollywood del radicalismo
islámico.
Es el lugar donde nació Osama Bin Laden y
donde se forjó la ideología SALAFISTA, que
inspira a grupos terroristas en todo el mundo.
En las calles de Riad, las mujeres tienen
que ir completamente tapadas, no pueden conducir
y son comunes las lapidaciones a infieles.
Por supuesto que está terminante prohibido
construir cualquier edificio religioso que
no sea una mezquita.
E incluso estas, tienen que estar sometidas
al control estricto de los clérigos más
radicales para asegurarse de que no haya ningún
resquicio para el Islám moderado.
Y todo ese dinero que gana Arabia Saudita
con la venta de su petróleo sirve para financiar
más mezquitas radicales en todo el mundo
o incluso, grupos terroristas como Al Qaeda.
Sin embargo y pese a todo, tanto EEUU como
el resto del mundo compran petróleo saudí
a calderadas ¿Cómo es esto posible?
¿Es por alguna razón geopolítica?
¿Hay alguna teoría de la conspiración?
Hoy vamos a responder a todas esas preguntas.
Y atentos que al final de este vídeo, tengo
una sorpresa para todos vosotros.
Pero antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
HISTORIA DEL PETRÓLEO SAUDÍ
Por sorprendente que parezca, Arabia Saudí
es un país extremadamente joven.
Hasta principios del siglo XX, la península
arábiga era un territorio dominado por el
imperio Otomano, es decir, lo que ahora es
Turquía.
Tras la I Guerra Mundial, los otomanos desaparecen
del mapa y los árabes se sumen en un sinfín
de guerras tribales por el control de la zona.
Pensad que el desierto de Arabia era el hogar
de montones de tribus nómadas lideradas por
pequeños monarcas.
Nada que ver con lo que entendemos por un
país como tal.
Finalmente, en los años 30, una de esas casas
reales en disputa, concretamente la de los
sauds, consigue conquistar al resto ayudada
por los británicos.
Así que, en 1932 nace el Reino de Arabia
Saudita.
Y, por cierto, era uno de los más pobres
del mundo.
Pensad que no tenían ni luz, ni coches ni
mucho menos carreteras.
Y cualquier ayuda extranjera era más que
bienvenida.
Sin embargo, años después, una empresa estadounidense,
la STANDARD OIL, descubre el primer yacimiento
de petróleo en la zona.
Y como ya sabéis los que seguís VisualPolitik,
el petróleo de Arabia es muy fácil de extraer
porque está a pocos metros de la superficie
y es de muy buena calidad.
Así que ¡Pum!
De la noche a la mañana, los saudíes se
hicieron millonarios ¿Verdad?
¡Bueno, esperad un momento porque no es tan
sencillo!
Extraer petróleo requiere tecnología, ingenieros,
máquinas especiales y, sobretodo MUCHO dinero.
Y, como os podéis imaginar, en un país de
nómadas, ni siquiera hay bancos, mucho menos
ingenieros o fondos de inversión.
Y por eso, las petroleras estadounidenses
eran imprescindibles para que los saudíes
pudieran convertir ese tesoro que tenían
bajo sus pies en dinero contante y sonante.
¡Peeeeero!
Los monarcas saudíes no eran tontos.
No iban a dejar que los estadounidenses se
llevaran todo el petróleo sin más.
Y por eso, se creó una empresa, la Arabian
American Oil Company: ARAMCO que como su propio
nombre indica, era lo que se conoce como una
Joint venture entre el Gobierno saudí y empresas
americanas como Texaco.
Como os decía, el petróleo de Arabia es
el más barato de extraer del mundo.
En Texas o California está más profundo
y además, necesitas comprar tierras y conseguir
permisos.
A fin de cuentas, en Estados Unidos existe
una cosa llamada propiedad privada.
Así que, si un granjero de Houston descubre
oro negro en su patio trasero y Texaco lo
quiere explotar, tiene que negociar con el
dueño para comprarle las tierras o alquilarlas.
Y nada de esto es barato.
Arabia, en cambio, son miles de kilómetros
cuadrados de desierto.
Y el dueño y señor de todo es el rey Abdul,
que también es socio de la ARAMCO.
Así que no importa el precio de mercado del
barril, los márgenes de beneficio siempre
van a ser más amplios que en cualquier otro
lugar.
Así empieza una bonita amistad entre Estados
Unidos y Arabia Saudí.
ARAMCO explota el petróleo del desierto y
después lo refina en distintas factorías,
muchas de las cuales están en suelo americano.
Mientras tanto, el Gobierno de Washington
protege los yacimientos con su propio ejército
a través de varias bases militares.
Y, por supuesto ¿En qué moneda se cobran
los beneficios de esos barriles de petróleo
que vende ARAMCO?
¡Efectivamente, en dólares!
Es decir, que Estados Unidos saca el petróleo,
vende el petróleo más rentable del planeta
y a la vez, vende sus propios dólares.
Todo son beneficios.
A cambio, los reyes saudíes se pegan una
vida de estrellas del rock.
Sí, es verdad que ya en aquella época eran
unos fanáticos religiosos.
Pero estamos en los años 40, 50 y 60.
Y los malos de la película no son los radicales
islámicos sino los comunistas.
Y, como os podéis imaginar, los saudíes,
con sus mezquitas y sus millones de petrodólares,
no eran muy amigos de esos ateos leninistas
de la Unión Soviética.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque las cosas
se tuercen!
En 1973, los saudíes se dan cuenta de que
son los dueños de la mitad del petróleo
que se consume en el mundo.
Y que tienen suficientes petrodólares ahorrados
como para imponer sus condiciones en el mercado.
Así surge la famosa crisis del petróleo
del 73.
Si queréis entender bien lo que ocurrió,
podéis pinchar en este vídeo de la esquina.
Al final del vídeo os vuelvo a poner el link.
¿Y cómo se salda la crisis del petróleo?
Pues termina con que la monarquía saudí
NACIONALIZA ARAMCO.
Es decir, que enorme margen de beneficios
ya no lo quieren compartir con las empresas
estadounidenses.
Lo quieren todo para ellos.
Y os preguntaréis.
Si Estados Unidos ya no gana dinero con el
petróleo saudí ¿Por qué lo siguen importando?
LA SEGURIDAD DEL SUMINISTRO
La crisis del 73 enseñó a todos los países
del mundo una lección muy importante: si
tu economía depende del petróleo, al menos,
no dependas de un único proveedor.
Dicho de otra forma, Estados Unidos tiene
sus propios recursos petroleros, sí.
Pero también pueden agotarse, pueden tener
averías o incluso sufrir ataques.
Por ejemplo, imaginad que un tornado en Texas
destruye un par de plantas de extracción.
O que un gasoducto, simplemente, se rompe
¿Pensáis que estas cosas no pueden ocurrir
en un país desarrollado?
Pues os equivocáis:
“Un oleoducto en Canadá derrama 200.000
litros de petróleo en tierras aborígenes”
Si todo tu suministro de petróleo depende
de un único proveedor, un desastre como este
puede suponer que una región se quede sin
gasolina por un tiempo que pueden ser días
o meses.
Por eso, para evitar estos problemas, tanto
Estados Unidos como el resto de países DIVERSIFICAN
sus proveedores.
Concretamente, en este caso, la mitad del
petróleo que se consume viene de los yacimientos
situados en suelo americano, que los explotan
empresas como Exxon Mobile o Chevron.
Pero la otra mitad, se importa.
Estas compañías norteamericanas negocian
acuerdos con las petrolíferas de otros países.
Y en contra de lo que podíais pensar, Arabia
Saudí, o más concretamente, ARAMCO, no es
el proveedor más importante.
El 40% del crudo que compra el Tío Sam, proviene
de Canadá, más concretamente, de los yacimientos
de la región de ALBERTA.
Las razones son muy lógica.
Son dos países que están uno al lado del
otro y que, además, tienen muy buenas relaciones.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque, a pesar
de todo, Arabia Saudí sigue siendo el segundo
proveedor más importante!
¿Por qué?
La primera razón es que los saudíes son
un productor de petróleo ESTABLE.
Y recalco esta palabra: Estable.
Es decir, pese a que ya han demostrado que
son capaces de cortar el suministro por razones
políticas, o que su régimen es una teocracia
islámica, Arabia es uno de los pocos países
que puede garantizar suministro continuamente
¿Por qué?
Pues precisamente por esos márgenes de beneficio
de los que os hablábamos antes.
Por ejemplo, los yacimientos de petróleo
en Gran Bretaña están ubicados en el mar
del Norte.
Eso significa que para extraer crudo, tienes
que montar una isla artificial y hacer una
perforación en el fondo del mar ¡Todo eso
es carísimo!
Algo parecido ocurre en Canadá o en Venezuela.
El crudo en estos lugares aparece mezclado
con arena y materiales sólidos.
Y todo eso lo complica muchísimo a la hora
de refinar el recurso fósil y convertirlo
en petróleo o plástico.
Sin embargo, en el desierto saudí, basta
con hacer una pequeña perforación y ¡PUM!
Chorros de petróleo de buenísima calidad
y fácil de refinar.
Esto significa que su coste de extracción
es muy bajo ¿Pero esto qué consecuencias
tiene para la continuidad del suministro?
¡Pues muchas!
Porque imaginad que el precio de mercado del
barril del petróleo baja.
Aquellos productores que necesitan gastar
más para extraer su crudo, dejan de obtener
beneficios cuando lo venden.
En muchos casos, incluso obtienen pérdidas
¿Recordáis el vídeo en el que os hablábamos
de Venezuela?
En este país, pese a que tienen toneladas
de petróleo, han paralizado la producción
porque el barril está tan barato, que ya
no ganan dinero.
En realidad, les sale más rentable importar
todo su consumo que extraerlo por su cuenta
¡Y no es por que no quieran!
A Nicolás Maduro le encantaría reactivar
sus plantas de extracción.
A fin de cuentas, su economía depende casi
al 100% de los recursos fósiles ¡Pero si
lo hiciera, perdería aún más dinero!
Sin embargo, Arabia Saudí tiene los costes
más bajos del mundo.
Así que, desde un punto de vista estrictamente
económico, nunca van a tener razones para
dejar de exportar su oro negro.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque esta no es
la única razón!
Todavía hay más.
PETRÓLEO LIGERO Y PETRÓLEO PESADO
Ni todo el petróleo es igual ni todas las
refinerías están diseñadas para procesar
el mismo tipo de crudo.
Es más, no todos los países tienen tecnología
suficiente para el refino.
¿Recordáis que México tiene que enviar
su preciado oro negro a Estados Unidos para
que se lo devuelvan convertido en gasolina?
Algo parecido ocurría también entre Venezuela
y Canadá.
Básicamente, los recursos fósiles, el “zumo
de dinosaurio”, es una mercancía que está
contínuamente viajando por todo el mundo.
En unos sitios lo extraen, en otros lo refinan
y en otros lo distribuyen.
No olvidéis que el mercado del petróleo
es un juego de empresas.
Sí, casi todas estas empresas son estatales,
a excepción de las estadounidenses que son
privadas.
Pero aún así, los acuerdos comerciales se
basan en criterios económicos.
Así que, aunque ARAMCO sea la empresa estatal
que explota el petróleo saudí, en muchos
casos necesita la tecnología especial que
le proporciona alguien como Exxon Mobile.
Por ejemplo, parte del crudo de ARAMCO se
refina en grandes factorías en el Golfo de
México.
Eso explica que os encontréis noticias como
esta:
“ARAMCO quiere reforzar su posición en
el Golfo de México comprand una planta de
refinería en Houston que está vendiendo
la empresa Lyondell Basell”.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque esto no es
todo!
Refinar petróleo es algo así como hacer
un cocktail con recursos de distintos tipos.
Para explicarlo de forma sencilla, el “zumo
de dinosaurio” que sale en Texas, es muy
líquido.
Tan líquido que los expertos lo llaman “petróleo
ligero”.
Y para poder convertir este jugo en denso
combustible con el que llenar los depósitos
de nuestros coches, o productos sólidos como
el plástico, necesitamos mezclarlo con un
crudo un poquito más espeso.
De otra forma, el proceso de refino podría
salir extremadamente caro.
Así que, lo más barato que puede hacer una
empresa de refino como Industrias KOCH o VALERO
ENERGY es comprar unos barriles de crudo texano,
que es muy líquido, y mezclarlo con otros
de crudo más espeso…
¡Y resulta, que el petróleo Saudí es perfecto
para hacer este cocktail!
Es más, parte del negocio de las empresas
petroleras estadounidenses consiste en eso,
en comprar crudo a distintos proveedores,
refinarlo, y después vender productos a todo
el Mundo.
Y se trata de un trabajo tan lucrativo como
puede ser la extracción pura y dura.
Y por eso, muchas empresas de países no petroleros
como la SHELL, que es de Países Bajos, hacen
pingües beneficios con el oro negro.
Y precisamente por esta, Arabia Saudita, a
través de su empresa ARAMCO, también quiere
su trozo en este pastel.
“ARAMCO ya es la co-propietaria, junto con
la Royal Dutch Shell, de Motiva, la planta
de refino más grande de EEUU, y ya han acordado
que para abril de 2017, ARAMCO tomará el
control total de los principales activos de
MOTIVA”
¡Pero esperad porque todavía hay más!
No olvidéis que Arabia Saudí es un país
crucial en medio oriente, y que tiene el TERCER
mayor ejército del mundo.
Y hay muchos intereses en materia de seguridad
que influyen en las relaciones entre la Casa
Blanca y la familia real saudí.
Pero de todo eso hablamos en este vídeo.
SI lo queréis ver, haced click aquí.
Y la pregunta es ¿Os parece sostenible mantener
relaciones comerciales tan intensas con un
país como Arabia Saudí?
¿Creéis que hay también razones políticas
por las cuales EEUU importa petróleo de Arabia
Saudí?
Y ahora viene la sorpresa!
Este mes de marzo voy a estar en España dando
3 charlas.
Me han invitado a participar en el Free Market
Road Show, que es una serie de eventos organizados
en varias ciudades de Europa.
Concretamente, yo estaré en Sevilla, Santiago
de Compostela y Gijón.
Si queréis acercaros, tenéis más detalles
en los enlaces de la descripción.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas.
Así que suscribiros al canal para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo!
Un abrazo y hasta pronto!

Por cierto, que esto que está sonando es
SEMENTAL, una banda de rock de México que
nos ha enviado su música.
Si os gusta, encontraréis más información
en los enlaces de la descripción.